la stessa maglia
altro giorno altro letto sempre a
[ __ ] e va bene quello a tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti ami solo video sono sono
veramente un fonico quando iniziò stevie
del tipo mi sono abbracciato da solo
bella tutti ragazzi venuti a questo
nuovo video sono farisei oggi siamo
substrato ho visto subito virtuali
impossible che non veri impossible write
mango ha provato che cazzo mi chiedi un
attimo ad e voce michele il casinò è ma
veramente
no ragazzi non ho capito sono serio che
cazzo successo che cosa c'è di difficile
ma tema o va bene non è possibile ci
arriva un millimetro ogni volta c'è
pazzesco ma guarda c'è l'ala puttanata
di sta roba che veramente incredibile
nei comics io skyroom ci sono le skype
roma anche su happy va bene l'icona
l'object ok clicca su un oggetto per
interagire
ma c'è la porta ebbene sono scemo io
giustamente la porta bisogno della
chiave dove la troviamo la chiave sulla
pagina non hai trovato niente va bene
nel cassetto
hai preso un codice segreto va bene e
quale cazzo è 6 calmo
giuro che questa non la sapevo ragazzi
però ci sono tre cose nella stanza è
facile non come i nani che ci mettevo
tipo la vita
ok ho trovato un non scrive driver
ok anche se c'era anche intuibile cosa
me ne fa devo svitare il lucchetto no
non svitare questa ho trovato la chiave
è i libri anche il caso servono scusami
non servono a niente ma si chissenefrega
tanto estate estate got the door don't
muro che in ascensore st porta cos'era
[Musica]
non ho capito ma ok l'importante è
vincere non partecipare vanno mentito
brown slow motion di dong eri sempre
quello che ragazzi mi stellette perché
si livelli arrivano nelle top dei
livelli di happy with kozuch anno di
bello sono tutti uguali fanno cagare
non c'è bisogno di votarlo 6
sopravvissuta invece io ti voto una
stella [ __ ] a farlo pagare sti
livelli ma perché finiscono imprint hop
c'è stranissimo è la o this is my forse
l'avrei fiume chidro hayden sempre place
nel taking back
[Musica]
dall'altro verso la fine sembrava che si
stesse tramutando in superman prove
spear shooter che cosa è piaciuta a e
ovviamente lo spiega prezzo space non fa
un cazzo
clicchi up sono scemo beh sì va bene che
ha però troppe cose c'è mica lo lancia
renan nasta non è che devo fare chissà
che cosa
space to shoot updown clicchi autori
lodo ok va bene l'altro non l'ho neanche
infilzato l'ho solo spinto action con la
mia mira di merda su riuscito a beccare
luke non so come adesso il mio obiettivo
ok io sto beccando tutti quelli ai quali
non sto ammirando io l'ho beccare steve
ok a una cosa che volevo fare l'ho fatta
una sola mancano quei due deficienti non
c'è però tipo mai
in tutto questo liuc è sopravvissuto non
si sa come ma va bene boltro 8 bit
ma che senso dormiva va bene che bello
timmy 8 bit che sarebbe luke ma va beh
ditemi se non è uguale a quello di imac
pixel adesso ragazzi è identico rega ma
uguale è sempre lì va a finire
halloween bel [ __ ] o una triste
vita è la prima volta che perdo in un
boltro la prima il primo tentativo
incredibile cioè non è vero succede solo
dettaglio ok e fa misto tiro che culo
che culo ai am anonymous certo sono poco
convinto della in due cose the line
ehi ciao zio
[Musica]
che gioco di merda mi spiegate cosa
appena successo perché non ho capito
cos'è sta roba
ma cos'è santo iddio è un serpente
schizzato e sono io nella intro dei miei
video quando faceva bene a tutti ragazze
più o meno cioè incredibile ce l'ho
fatta la prima volta senza sapere di
cosa parlasse il livello o perfetto
abbiamo diritto troppo perfetto ce
l'avevo fatta la prima volta non ce la
faccio e cioè così sto gioco è tutto
strano speed challenge magari sta roma
c'è il traguardo qua sotto
ma [ __ ] se non ci fosse quella
cazzo di bomba ok a c'è un cestino di
sotto quindi neanche neanche volendo
affanculo va belhaj ci ripensa c'è un
altro traguardo va bene mi chiama e
troppo in alto con non ci arriverò mai
nella vita
aspetta da te
e vabbè mica è un casino avere caso
livello assurdo ma sapete io vi dico
faccio normale voglio fa sotto porca
[ __ ]
poi come ho fatto a mancarla data è mica
quanto sei storto dai ma frate va bene
senti ci vado 18 prova non so niente un
rischio non riesco a raggiungere nessuno
dei quattro traguardi ci sono quattro ma
dai è zio ma veramente
nell'anno tutto deadpool challenge
ragazzi il livello di deadpool è una
figata sul serio
devono beccare tutte le vie questi qua
ok getting better si va fino adesso è
semplice poi ci sarà un dosso che ci
sarà chi fu un gigante tipo adesso
stesse veloce qual è il mio potere non
potere o potere delle scimmie potrete la
rigenerazione giusto sono così fiero
grazie ed apple sono anch'io contento di
esserti amico
ma veramente ma quanto è fatto bene
madonna è bellissimo sembra che abbia un
pene nel taschino però vabbè impossible
a notte ormai ragazzi ci siamo buttati
con gli imposti voi quindi facciamo lì a
prescindere
mi piace che cosa stranissima aspetta
che ci riprovo porca vacca laida dai
fratello allora perché se vado piano
forse adesso sta a me non ci credo piano
piano pianissimo pianisti copia sei
scemo di testa bravo complimenti ma dai
raga va impossibile ma come sono morto
come cazzo sono rimasto cioè un ragazzo
sto cliccando niente ha proprio a vedere
se ciò del tempino è non c'è il tempismo
no no sì sì pensavo che da morto non mi
facesse a raggiungere traguardi invece
si perfetto va bene swing blog 9 amica
be by taylor brava taylor e lo space
della storia proprio ok
questo è un livello fatto bene più o
meno
ok perfetto cos'è sta roba non so perché
l'amica e vi sembrano due occhi mi
inquieta un sacco devo stare sdraiato va
bene ciò il casco lì c'è scritto di
andare senza casco va bene lo stesso va
bene lo stesso dove dobbiamo andare a
devo aggrapparmi qua sotto va bene va
beh ma è figo soliva almeno veramente
fatto bene un rock swing decente per una
volta nella vita
ma ecco dov'è finito il pallone di zaza
l'ho trovato è andato un po a [ __ ]
prolo c'è c'è l'importante che c'è
d'accordo ragazzi facciamo un paio di
miei livelli visto che da una vita che
non li faccio tipo fa vj non nasce ma
già fa vj alla nonna scema ma se i
divertenti allo stesso
ciò fa vj sono silver wing tua nonna è
scema posso chiederti che cazzo cioè
contro mia nonna seriamente capito
questa cosa va bene forse ciò più il
personaggio scemo che altro credo è
subito cosa sta facendo ed i costumi
orff brutto figlio di [ __ ] ma perché
stai tipo guardando indietro ma sei
scemo chi para il momento di fare yoga è
di quest'anno seriamente chi sta anche
bene se vuoi aver acquisito che i
capezzoli la vj slam dunk schiaccia come
michael jordan in un in un eccezionale
campo 3 di schiacciare come michael ma
schiacciare in che senso aspetta un
attimo ma non ha il problema è che non
arrivò alla palla dovrei sa ma cazzo è
la salvezza o come sta non volevo
disturbarci perdonami ma non ci voglio
credere lega ma come facciano a mancare
la palla premio amiche a un'ora e poi ed
un'ora per prenderle non ho fatto
neanche canestro c'è ma come siamo messi
già fatta stavolta stava dove cazzo
va bene non ho visto dove è rimasta la
palla però che i favi générale adventure
never press space gliel'ho premuto
subito regalo immediatamente cosa devo
fare ma in realtà sapeva che l'avrei
premuto perché sta andando lo stesso
porca [ __ ] che se mi sono visto un
tronco davanti per un millisecondo cazzo
sta andando rigate un'ora che o dio
[Musica]
ok ma dei ragazzi direi che posso
concludere qui dopo questo perché è
santo di dio non ho capito una sega di
quello che è successo ma ok dakar
ragazzi spero che video vi sia piaciuto
un bel pollice in su per la mia presa da
con le palle da basket è leggendaria
veramente michael giorni non sarebbe
fiero di sé quando si dice che non
riesce a far canestro no io neanche la
palla che vola cosa base di prendere la
palla non riesco fantastico vero che vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa il mio vissuto
sotto un commento è un mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook come nei video a
tornare descrizione seno e se non si
discute di cividino proseguito la
ragazza